thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
how are you guys doing
as many of you will know Andrew Tay has
been incarcerated without charge for
some time subsequently put on the house
arrest and now this is the first BBC
interview of this guy the first
interview of his kind
that has just landed actually where he
was talking to the BBC in fact a docile
and Placid
um interviewer very weak body language
very weak argumentation
and I wanted to actually do kind of
analysis on this so let's take a look at
the first point she makes and come back
and respond in kind you've got the
police naming You by name as someone who
has a harmful influence
influence children and on women in the
UK and elsewhere because of the things
you say so the first point she makes is
about the police and she uses it as a
kind of appeal to Authority now aside
from being fallacious the problem here
is what makes the police any kind of
authority anyways I mean she would have
been better off actually mentioning
sociological experts because this is a
sociological case the effect of Andrew
tape she would have been better off
mentioning an academic but even that is
problematic because who cares I mean
this is just opinions anyway but the
point is the police does not represent
the Judiciary in the UK let alone uh can
impose judicial ruling so the fact that
she mentions the police as some kind of
an important opinion when we know that
this institution in the United Kingdom
is one which has been repeatedly accused
of institutional racism and Corruption
and all kinds of problems is it
self-problematic let's see the second
point and respond you're the most
dangerous man in the world I've said I'm
the most dangerous man in the world
I mean this is almost comical at this
point it's actually
laughable at the point of comicality
that's what I would say I mean this is
is you're you're meeting somebody here
you're meant to be representing alleged
victims of Major Crimes and this is the
strongest argument that you can present
I mean this is the strongest thing you
can say
I think you do a great disservice okay
to those individuals who want this man
to be questioned in a harsh manner in an
interrogative manner because is this the
strongest thing you can provide you said
you said you said that you're the most
dangerous man in the world I mean
you can bring almost any MMA fighter who
said something very similar to that you
go into a question of them on that kind
of thing he's a fighter he's a
he has a track record of being a
kickboxing champion bring Mike Tyson he
says the same thing bring Muhammad Ali
said the same thing is this is this a
joke or something so let's see what she
says after that you've also said that a
woman's intimate Parts belong to her
male part I'm glad you find that funny I
found this quite actually malevolent and
malicious what she did after that after
he was laughing at this point she says
uh you said about women's you that a man
owns the intimate parts of women and
then I'm glad you found that funny and
he was already laughing at the first
thing that she mentioned so as if to
make him to implicate him into doing
something which she didn't which is
laugh at the point about finding women's
private parts or owning them or whatever
it may be so I found this actually quite
malicious and disingenuous inauthentic
this shows weakness and insecurity
actually on her behalf because she
couldn't elicit anything from him so she
was trying to force the issue and
contrive something which wasn't even
there so let's take a look at the next
part of this interview England which is
a failing nation which has nice crime
going to the roof violence going through
the roof men's mental health going
through the roof I like this monologue
by Tate because he starts off by talking
about some issues because she mentioned
two or three organizations in the United
Kingdom she says and he States look
England's got its own problems and which
is true we've got a knife crime epidemic
all these things that he mentioned is
absolutely true I mean I looked at some
statistics 50 000 people I think in 2019
were stabbed in the United Kingdom there
are some bigger fish to fry but she's
here talking about us to a social
influencer about his um words online she
wouldn't do that really with people of
ethnic backgrounds okay that potentially
uh Grime artists and and why why are
these people not questioned on the same
level I don't understand that we have
people all over London for example what
do they call it Grime and there's
another one called drill drill out you
know that thank you drill artists and so
on talking about all kinds of things why
don't you if this is the standard if
this is the problem here why don't you
talk to these people about these things
I think it's because there's a cultural
reasoning for it
maybe it's because he's saying it in
prose maybe why not comedians be
scrutinized in the same manner so I feel
like there's a massive double standard
going on here let's see the next thing
that she states
excuse me you have an image of financial
success but it comes along with
attitudes towards women that are really
problematic this is a very unusual point
isn't it she says that you you know you
have these uh this financial success but
then you then you have the side order
she mentions at one point of misogyny
well that's the point that you're
asserting the point so you have to bring
the evidence
I mean you're making you're giving your
opinion at this point you're meant to be
eliciting as the look you're an
interrogator here well at least you're
attempting to be an interrogator so you
should be trying to elicit something
from him trying to catch him try to
Corner him you're just imposing your
opinion at this stage it's actually
quite embarrassing I'm surprised you
even worked for the BBC I'm I'm
surprised they put you on this project I
don't know why they put the BBC should
have put something like Jeremy Paxman a
Jeremy Paxman type to to go against Toe
to Toe with this guy because quite
frankly this is no match it's like
putting a lightweight with a heavyweight
this is embarrassing why are they doing
this I wanted to see more I wanted to
see him being tested more because there
were some serious allegations I mean
there were some serious allegations he
should have been tested on these
allegations and like he correctly said
it should have been talk about why was
he incarcerated for this long why is the
justice system as it is in Romania why
was there no discussion from Amnesty
International and other you know human
rights organizations about him being
incarcerated without charge because if
it was that guy Scofield what's his name
Philip Schofield
why don't they interrogate him on these
issues like that well I think they talk
about him like that
huh because the reason why is because he
represents to a large extent the same
ideological belief systems
they've kind of you know if anything not
done that with him they wouldn't do that
with him I want to see that with him I
want to see that kind of attitude with
him
and this is uh the next point that I
want to mention here let's see what she
says here she she states something about
if you said
women lose Authority and I think this is
a very telling point because she's
bringing her own ideological baggage
here let's take a look at this point
here
[Music]
who do you mean by most women most white
women most western women most World
women if you go to Nigeria and ask women
there would you want to lose Authority I
want you if you went to Mali if you went
to Malaysia what do you mean by most
women in the world well we have lots of
evidence to show that women in these
parts of the world they don't believe in
the kind of egalitarian ideological
points that you believe that you clearly
are trying to espouse vomit on us shove
down our throats quite frankly
shove down our throats
Colonial feminism I don't think the
majority of women in the world today
believe in the kind of colonial Western
feminism of the
egalitarian system that you believe in
frankly so if you ask most women what
you mean Western women did that have to
be white or can they be from other races
what about other religions
what kind of woman was what do you mean
by Authority anyway
and frankly let's go to Western women
because I mean maybe she means western
women she says if you ask most women
let's go to Western women would you
relinquish okay some of your
quote-unquote Authority decision making
capability let's say for the single
argument that's what she might mean in a
relationship that she would otherwise
have
for a degree of protection I think they
would actually and the evidence of that
is in some of the studies like the
famous study by Queen quite a q i n g on
hypergamy which indicates that the
majority of Western women would actually
go for a man who's got more money which
would probably put them in a subordinate
position in terms of decision-making
capabilities but for that extra
financial protection
so I think there is a case to be made
that if you go and ask most women would
they lose Authority in relationship to
be treated not to be treated as equals
or whatever it is to relinquish part of
their Authority I think they would
actually depending on how that I think
many women would do that
but once again you have to Define your
terms and it becomes a childish argument
almost childish to a point of comicality
is this what it's resorting to and it
gets even worse she's a BBC
representative this is the strongest
argument she's giving to a man who's who
is influential although she doesn't want
to agree with that or at least to the
extent which she's claiming someone
broke into this house right now it was a
homicidal maniac I would expect me and
the other men in this room to stand up
and face them while you would have went
you and the other women in this room
could protect yourselves I would
actually believe the men should go and
engage the attacker I believe that so he
makes a really good point here he says
if someone broke his eye I think this is
a fantastic point
because it shows you this idea of Rights
and responsibility Paradigm and this is
a staple part of traditional gender
roles yes you sacrifice parts of your
so-called rights
but then you also relinquish
where you forego part of the
responsibilities that are required that
go with that right which means that you
get additional protection which means
yes I promise you that woman there with
her weak body language Crossing her arms
asking docile questions that individual
that woman there representing the BBC in
the most abysmal way possible
that individual if there was any level
of physical threat that faced her she
would rely on men undoubtedly in that
house to protect her and she would feel
nothing about that she would feel no
sense of uh she would feel totally
entitled to that in fact she would feel
totally entitled to that
so yes yeah I think he made a very good
point about if someone broke into this
house right now that's why she
circumnavigated that point these are the
points that we're not addressing the
fact that the Ukrainian situation yes
women and children can go back to their
countries or to another country and be
rescued but then men have to fight these
things are being ignored by Western
feminists they are being ignored
that the entitlement is there but the
rights and responsibility and that's why
he's become influential and famous
because he's speaking to those facts
true facts which women like this yes are
ignoring
they're ignoring these points
so
that's another Point Let's see what she
says here because it gets even worse I
mean by the moment she gets even weaker
why are so many women saying that when
their boyfriends start following you
they're not they experience more control
so many they experience more abuse how
many what women are you talking about
you're not presenting any peer-reviewed
sociological data here
you're giving anecdotal evidence
and how do we know that the correlation
equals the causation I mean I don't
waste my time with this anyway anymore
but the point is this is that look
say what you want about the West there's
one thing that Western legal systems
have which is called natural Justice
that people are innocent until proven
guilty there's one thing I would say
that this BBC representative failed to
do which is interrogate him properly
give him a run for his money okay
because at the end of the day he is
someone who can speak well you should
bring someone who can speak well and
test him
the BBC failed here she failed here and
actually shows a greater agenda at hand
which is that these people here
are desperate
desperate
to force their narrative down our
throats and I say I think the world has
had enough I think people have had
enough and now the elephant in the room
needs to be addressed which is
feminism even true
why that we sub why do we interrogate
feminism
obviously we don't believe it is I mean
but let's let's cross examine feminism
that you believe in so strongly
is it good for women
is is it harmful for women let's have
these conversations because that's
really the conversation he represents a
counter current to the dominant
narrative
in the Western World yes there are some
serious allegations and I'll be honest
with you yes there are words and
statements that he's made which would
have been much better off not making
these things
especially in Game Theory they've got
this idea of the the infinite player you
know the infinite players the one who
thinks about the the finite usually I
mean beats a finite player the infinite
player someone who continues and thinks
about doing the same work as they're
doing for for a very long time was the
finite player thinks of doing the work
that they're doing for a short period of
time I think Andrew Tate needed to think
more a bit more like an infinite player
frankly from a game theory perspective
because a lot of these statements that
he made are not self-contained and they
could have been self-contained and that
would be my criticism Foundry he could
have had more self-contained statements
because a lot of them now are being used
misappropriated but frankly he he won
this one definitely it was an easy
victory for him I think he found it very
comfortable and this woman here she's
really shamed herself
um I think she should quit her job
actually
I think
I think she's going her job and I will
suffice with that
the prophet Muhammad
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale